[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hello everybody how you doing my name is
pete also known as naldo here to give
you all a little bit of a
little insight of this new game called
v-rising
um
it is pretty hot right now on twitch and
i think the reason for that is because
it it really really has filled the gap
for uh everybody
uh involving a couple of different
aspects of uh you know genres that we
haven't seen in a while so um let's kind
of get into it uh
the
v rising or vampire rising you play as a
vampire
which is uh you know just rebirthed and
you are a uh you know
um
lonely old vampire now you come out of
your casket and you are forced to kind
of craft your way and build your
yourself back into
vampire
vampire kingdom-esque life i guess you
can say
uh you have very very minimal powers you
have
no weapons you have no nothing
so the reason why this game is so unique
and so enjoyable and
why i've even taken the time to flip my
my personal
server over to a verizon server is
because
the game
is so much fun playing with other people
and especially with my community uh that
we ended up wanting to play it together
you take so you
so
long story short um
the end game there's multiple different
end games uh for this or you know one
ginormous one which is the pvp towards
other types of vampires uh for myself
though and for a lot of people my
community we didn't want to do the pvp
portion uh we wanted to do the a
building of our castles which are pretty
freaking cool looking and b
make sure we can get as many of the v
powers as possible
now
the v powers
what they end up doing is they enhance
your vampire
now
you end up doing that by going on
missions you killing this special
or i should say weakening this special
uh
person in game and then drinking their
blood once you do that you end up
gaining the v power
now one of the first ones you do is you
are going after from what i remember is
a wolf
um you go after the wolf you kill him
you take the v power it allows you to
transform into a wolf
pretty freaking cool
um there's also the ability to turn to
rats bears there's so many different
abilities you can do
um but i think that the main focus uh
for this game was intended for the pvp
um
the game itself it you know the graphics
on it aren't too bad they're okay they
seem very you know copy and paste uh for
different objects within the world for
like you know trees and and blocks of
oars and and you know the people and uh
you know that and you know placing
uh you know mobs and stuff like that but
the cool thing about it i like
is that the
the
specialized units like the ones i was
talking about with the v powers
they end up having the ability to you
know look unique and having those unique
abilities
um
for instance you'll eventually find
people that are like poachers that are
going to shoot arrows and things like
that
but when you kind of progress more
you're then going to be asked to go
after
um this
frost's uh archer
and um you know then you'll have that
archer will look different and feel
different fight different the ai is
different with it so it's really really
unique and really really cool and i
really enjoy it
so it's just something to kind of you
know
to look at it and to have some fun with
now
uh i wanted to say that the
replayability on it is pretty high uh
because
you know some well i shouldn't say
replaying the whole game but the game
itself is long
um
the
the castle deteriorates over time so you
want to continue to make sure you're
doing that your
uh you know your weapons and stuff have
to be upgraded uh there's no leveling
system which i kind of thought was
interesting it's all based on your
weapon and your gear which means you
have to farm to get that stuff and then
you upgrade from there
so i'm i really did enjoy you know
playing this game and and do enjoy
playing this game uh so it's definitely
something you can look at uh the the
graphics are like i was talking about uh
the sounds on them you know they're
pretty they're pretty good i kind of
like the you know the fighting sounds
everything seems pretty on point for it
uh and i really really do like it now
like i said the
we ended up making the v server of the v
rising server because we wanted our own
server to play on because we didn't want
to go to some random server that no one
really had any any control over so it's
just something to to kind of put out
there so it's a lot of fun it's really
good so i would definitely recommend
going out and picking it up uh if you
get some time pick it up play with some
friends have some fun you know and um
you know you'll definitely need some
friends to play with when you eventually
are going after some of these later
monsters um i saw a couple of friends
that were streaming and playing and they
were going after a couple of the later v
monsters with the v powers and they were
uh too difficult to kill on their own so
i
i think it's kind of cool i'm kind of
nervous because if i go after them and i
don't have a friends online i'm like
am i going to be like stomped what's
going to happen so it's really really
cool on that aspect and the night and
day aspect of it oh you know you have uh
let's say 24 hours of a day
and you have uh
you know
uh three-fourths of it a night and
one-fourth of it is the daytime and in
the daytime if you hit with the sun
you're a vampire obviously you get
cooked and burned so
it really really makes you
you know time everything correctly and
makes you want to
you know
have everything done correctly and time
correctly so you can get in do what you
gotta do get out like i had to make two
bases one on each side of the map to
make sure that i could uh you know had a
place to you know go on a coffin to
protect myself so it was very very
unique and very enjoyable so
uh if if you're looking to pick up
v-rising you know it's pretty cheap on
steam from what i saw so
make sure you go pick it up it's really
really good and it's enjoyable so
my name is pete also known as sneldo i
stream on twitch uh five nights a week
from monday to friday from 3 p.m to 11
p.m that's s n s-n-a-l-y-d-o
uh and then you go on there and you know
by all means i am there
uh you know discord uh twitter facebook
about facebook uh
uh twitter discord uh instagram things
like that um i am there um and make sure
you check out the iron lords podcast
every single sunday and uh go to
lords2gaming.net for all of your gaming
needs uh thank you again for everything
uh and i will see you all soon thank you
very much bye everybody
you
so
foreign
[Music]
you